all right let's get into what was an
insane weekend Donald Trump held his
first official 2024 rally now I know the
year is 2023. what I mean is the first
rally for his 2024 campaign and it went
bad very quickly the location was Waco
Texas we should not ignore the
significance of on the 30th Anniversary
roughly of The Siege at Waco of the
Branch Davidians that Donald Trump chose
to hold his rally in that very location
and in fact he opened the rally with
totally apocalyptic messaging about how
2024 is the final battle and uh using
exactly that type of disastrous imagery
that is often associated with the Waco
Siege
and 2024 is the final battle that's
going to be the big one is it if you put
me back in the White House their reign
will be over and America will be a free
Nation once again again coming as a
surprise to many of us that America is
not currently a free nation very
confusing statement
our enemies are desperate to stop us
because they know that we are the only
ones who can stop them they know that
classic and standard fascistic messaging
where I alone can fix it you know
there's never been a movement like this
that's true of our country that's true
in the history of almost every country
let's hope
Maga make America great again America
First Call whatever you want
but I will tell you there's never been
in history look at this crowd as far as
the eye can see we flew over it was a
beautiful sight as far as the eye
concern now the crowd was animated at
this early stage of the very very long
rally but they very quickly settled and
quieted down including When Donald Trump
bragged about his passing a brain injury
screening test which many people uh I
guess are not finding as convincing as
maybe they once did
should I do
should I do some of them at times
and you know it was after that
it was after that that nobody called me
stupid anymore it was right because I
never liked that narrative I don't like
the word stupid but other people are
very stupid
he doesn't like the word he doesn't like
the narrative as applied to himself but
he'll immediately apply it to others
Donald Trump did very aggressively go
after Ron DeSantis he even told it
wasn't even a sir story it was uh he
came to me with tears in his eyes story
it's it's beyond parody at this point
Congressman Wesley I was a good speech
you guys
but they've been very loyal but I'm a
loyalist and and when a man comes to me
tears in his eyes
he said almost nothing in the polls it's
crazy how many men big strong guys are
constantly crying around Trump and he's
fighting somebody that's at 42 and he's
got almost 30 million dollars in the
bank yeah he was crying like a dog is it
almost nothing he's got no cash
and I said I can't give you an
endorsement there's no way you can win
you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell you right he forwarded a little bit
just a little bit on impeachment hoax
number one impeachment hooks number two
meaning on television because I didn't
know him very well but I saw him so he
came and he really wanted I said you
can't win can you how do you can win sir
if you endorsed me I'll win please
please sir endorse me
sir you're such a good president I just
need the endorsement I'm dead
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture okay anyway so people just
bursting into tears around Trump all the
time at another very bizarre moment
Trump claimed that a very famous man
recently asked him how he puts his
clothing on
him
almost everybody probably would have
heard if I'm a businessman
I saw him about two weeks ago he said to
me could I ask you I never even liked
them very much to be honest but he did
say it he said can I speak to you for a
second
Mr President sir
how do you take it I said take what
your coffee sir
you take I wouldn't know what to do well
we're very proud of the former president
he passed a brain injury screening test
and he also dresses himself all by
himself every single day and that alone
probably makes him qualified to do
something I don't know uh Donald Trump
with a very
um a very important message to women for
inclusivity in 2024.
I never liked horse face I never liked
it's just not it's terrible thing
[Applause]
that wouldn't be the one right there is
no one we have a great first lady
yeah
so uh a very inviting message of Trump's
respect for women there as you can see
referring of course to Stormy Daniels
Donald Trump once again playing up this
entire baby bonuses thing we will
support baby bonuses so many people like
that for the new baby boom that will be
coming
we need babies all of this is we need
babies now of course we have a sort of
baby bonus already it's called a child
tax credit Democrats and many on the
left want to increase it and make it
permanent it would be a baby bonus it
would be an incentive to have children
which whether you like that or not it's
what Trump is talking about but they
don't want to do that and much like with
NAFTA and usmca it seems Trump's plan is
sort of like to get rid of what we have
and replace it with the exact same thing
but to give it a different name Donald
Trump continuing the attacks on a New
York Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg calling
New York prosecutors absolute human scum
but the two lead prosecutors absolute
human scum yeah
1A Hillary Clinton lawyer from a Hillary
Clinton Law Firm do you believe does
anybody know why they say Clinton I I
mean Marjorie Taylor green says Clinton
and she's from the south and Trump says
Clinton and he's from Queens is it a
deliberate sort of pejorative sort of
the way some people might say Tulsi
gabbard I don't know I don't know who
would say that uh what is it what is it
about that and then lastly Trump
bringing back the creepy Q Anon music
and bemoaning how airports function
Nation where once revered airports are
dirty
they're a crowded mess you sit and wait
for hours and then are notified that the
plane won't leave and they have no idea
when it will Trump is saying this
minutes before getting onto his private
plane and taking off and flying directly
home so not not the most relatable
moment of the speech so dangerous
rhetoric
a semi comatose crowd as the speech went
longer and longer you know you wait all
day in the direct sun with the fetid
porta potties and next thing you know
the speech finally starts and it's a
snoozer so I I sympathize with the crowd
in a sense I would not go to one of
these things but where I want to go next
is someone we know did go to this thing
and he stood in the Sun and he got some
wild material for us that's Luke Beasley
let's talk about that next
as many of my viewers and listeners of
course know I have many family members
who work in the field of mental health
and I think one of the most important
things that we can do is to both
increase access and reduce stigma when
it comes to Mental Health Services and
that's why I am thrilled that one of our
sponsors today is better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it is 100 online with better
help you can tap into a network of over
25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists an important word therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues you answer a few questions about
your needs and your preferences and
better help will match you with a
therapist that meets your needs you can
then talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable could be text could be
chat phone video call you can message
your therapist anytime you can schedule
live sessions when it's convenient and
if your therapist isn't the right fit
for any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below